-Our next guest is an
Emmy-nominated writer, comedian,
and actor you know from his work
on "Saturday Night Live."
He stars in the scripted podcast
"Hot White Heist,"
which is available exclusively
through Audible.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Bowen Yang.
How are you, Bowen?
-Hi, Seth. I'm good.
What an honor to be in
this Denverite show,
like, just to share the bill
with Peyton.
-That's right.
You spent time in Colorado
and of course, Peyton Mannin
lives there now.
I did not realize how Rock
Mountain high tonight was.
-I get altitude sickness
whenever I go back,
so I've lost my powers.
-Did you really?
You've just been gone
for a little amount of time,
and you can't go back?
-I can't go back, no.
-Wow, and that probably explains
why you're in Georgia now.
-Exactly, I'm in Georgia.
I'm fulfilling my uncle duties
in Georgia for the first tim
since the pandemic.
It's wonderful.
-Do you have nieces and nephews,
one of each?
What do you got?
-I got two nieces.
The older one is three.
She's just starting to tal
and express herself
and set her own boundaries
or defy others.
And it's interesting.
Right now, we're teaching he
how to cough properly.
-Oh, got you.
-Just to cover your mouth.
It's really -- It's really
strange to do it in public
to teach a child how to coug
properly in public.
But I'm doing more than the CD
is in terms of,
like, knowing how to do --
-Yeah.
I mean, I wouldn't call yo
a first responder,
but it does seem like
you're responsive.
-There you go.
Tertiary responder? Happy to be.
-Are you good with kids
historically?
-No. In fact, I think this i
just kind of confirming
for myself that I'm terrible
with kids.
The older niece is getting upset
and she's crying sometimes
then I'll just turn around
and go,
"Ellie, I'm not seeing any
tears," like an acting coach
[ Laughter ]
Like, I'm awful.
And then the other day, she wa
drinking water out of a cup.
She refused to have ice in it.
She loves Elsa from "Frozen,
however.
And I said to her, I said,
"Ellie, you know who loves ice
is Elsa.
And if you love Elsa,
shouldn't you love ice?"
And she -- Her eyes glazed ove
and I think I throttled he
into an existential crisis
[ Laughter ]
So I'm terrible with kids.
-Well, you're good at
a lot of other things,
including this podcast.
This is a "Heist" Audible
podcast.
-Yes.
-It's an all-queer cast.
And I want you to explain it
You were on the "Today" show
and they asked you
to explain it.
And then they told you to
remember it was a morning show
Look, it's a different sid
of morning right now.
We're on the other side
of midnight.
Go wild.
Explain it how you wish.
-What I couldn't say to
Jenna Bush Hager was that it i
an Audible-scripted podcas
about a sperm-bank heist
in which we were stealing
the sperm
of all of our past president
since Kennedy
and the sperm of
Yo-Yo Ma, Mark Zuckerberg,
the guy who invented the Segway.
Our greatest minds
have their sperm stored
under the Space Needle
and we have to pull off
an all-queer heist
in order to serve a group of
lesbian militants in Montana
-[ Laughs ]
-That's the pitch.
-That's a very good pitch.
And I feel like people could'v
handled that in the morning.
I got to be honest.
I think that that would be fine.
-Yeah, I think so too.
-I want to ask. You play
a sort of grifter of sorts
You came to New York
to go to NYU.
Were you one of those sort o
clear-eyed maybe, sort of mayb
overtrusting people when
you first got to New York?
-Absolutely. I was swindled ou
of my entire net worth
within two months
of moving here.
It was Halloween 2008,
a week before the election
and I decided to walk over
to the parade.
Or no, I was walking
to some dorm,
and I crossed the street
at Union Square.
And someone stopped me and said,
"Hey, you stepped on
my glasses"
and held up this pair
of shattered frames,
and he was like,
"I need these to see.
You need to pay me $100
right now."
I said, "I am so sorry.
I don't believe I did that
but if I did,
I don't have the money."
He kept following me,
and then I had gotten --
I had acquiesced at that point
I was just like, "Fine, you ca
come with me to the ATM.
I need to pick up some cash,
but I have to tell you,
I have $13 in my bank accoun
right now,
so I do need to call my father
so he could deposit
at least $7 for me
to give you $20."
And so then, his face fell and
he was like, "Oh, okay, sure."
And I think he felt sorry for me
at that point,
so that when we were waiting for
the money to transfer
at the ATM, he's making really
really polite small talk with me
and being like, "You know,
there's this parade every year
and it's really wonderful.
Oh, you just moved to New York
You'd love this parade."
He was being very kind to me
afterward.
-That's very nice. He realized
you were going to be out
20 bucks but he didn't wan
your whole night to be a wash.
-Exactly.
-You had such a wonderful season
on "SNL."
Congratulations.
I think the thing that
I would've least predicted maybe
going into the season is tha
you would play Fran Lebowitz
I think that I may be equall
enamored with Fran to you.
How did this even come about
Because it's not, let's say,
natural casting.
-No, it's not.
But I kind of wanted to go
for it anyway.
I was just, let's say, under the
influence of something in be
watching "Pretend It's a City.
And I thought to myself,
"I'm going to play her.
I'm going to play her
on 'Update.'"
And then I texted one of
the writers, Sudi Green,
a very good friend and I said,
"I have this crazy idea,
but I think I have to play
Fran Lebowitz on 'Update.'
And then she said,
"That's great.
Let's get Kyle as Scorsese."
I was like, "Perfect."
And then, the next day,
Anna Drezen, our head writer
texted me, "Crazy idea,
but I think you should pla
Fran Lebowitz on 'Update.'
I said, "Sudi and I had
the same thought."
And then we did it
the Saturday afterwards.
And I was like, this is
the best part of working here,
is that you get to ideate
something so silly
the week before and then have it
be on TV the next week.
-Everyone I talked to loved it
and yet, there was one person,
a sort of notable person
who did not care for it
and recently went on the recor
as not caring for it.
-That's right.
Fran herself has gone from -
Andy Cohen had
reached out for comment.
She had said that she has
no interest in seeing it,
which I loved at the time.
And then I think last week
she's gone on record
to say that
she does not like it.
And so I think that's
confirmation that she's seen i
and that she doesn't
care for it.
And I think that's the highest
compliment you can possibly ge
from someone like Fran.
-I think that's right.
I think that
if Fran Lebowitz said,
"Oh, my God, I loved it, and
it's so cool to be on 'SNL,'
like, it would just
ruin everything.
-Terrible, yeah, absolutely.
So I wear it as a badge of honor
that she did not like
my portrayal of her.
I probably wouldn't either
If, like, someone who is like so
demographically opposite of me
portrayed me, I'd be like,
"Come on." So no.
-I bet even if you were
demographically
right on the nose, she probabl
would've felt the same way
-[ Laughs ]
Okay, fair, fair.
-I mean, she's Fran Lebowitz
We'll give her a lot of spac
to be critical of things.
-Sure. Absolutely.
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
Congrats again on
another great year.
And congrats on the podcast.
Thanks for being here, Bowen
-Thanks, Seth.
-"Hot White Heist" --
here it is --
is available exclusively
through Audible.